hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today is a brief introduction
to the very complicated topic of cell
respiration so respiration begins with
something called mycologists glycolysis
literally means sugar splitting Blanco
sugar like glucose lysis splitting so it
begins with glucose which comes from the
food that we ingest and glucose is
converted to a molecule called pyruvate
in ten enzymatically catalyzed steps
pyruvate another name for pyruvate is
pyruvic acid and this happens in the
cytosol now there are a couple of things
that are made in glycolysis one is ATP
so ATP or adenosine triphosphate is a
very important way that the cells stores
energy so glycolysis is taking energy
from glucose and storing it in ATP now a
lot of the energy from glucose is still
within pyruvate also there are some
high-energy electrons that have been
taken from glucose and put into
something called an electron carrier
known as NADH now at this point if the
cell is in an oxygen poor environment
there's not enough oxygen for it to
continue with normal aerobic respiration
it will proceed in two different types
of fermentation pathways also known as
an aerobic respiration so respiration
without oxygen this is not the most
efficient and you don't get much ATP
from it however itself does have oxygen
it can proceed with aerobic respiration
which is the rest of what we're going to
be talking about today
that is when pyruvate enters the
mitochondrion so this happened in the
cytosol now the product of glycolysis
has to enter the mitochondrion which is
one of the organelles the mitochondrion
is made up of two membranes so there is
an outer membrane an inner membrane
which has all of these folds the folds
are called pre-stain the space between
the outer and inner membrane is known as
the inter membrane space so that's
what's here and then there is the
mitochondrial matrix which is what is
inside the inner membrane so pyruvate
moves into the mitochondrion
specifically into the matrix where it is
oxidized the process of pyruvate
oxidation generates another one of these
electron carriers NADH which remember is
just a way for the cell to remove energy
further from pyruvate now the product of
pyruvate oxidation is known as acetyl co
a acetyl co a then enters the Krebs
cycle
the krebs cycle has a few different
names it's also called the citric acid
cycle the tricarboxylic acid cycle and
the TCA cycle but they're all the same
names for this process which is also
happening still in the mitochondrial
matrix the Krebs cycle is generating a
few electron carriers more NADH which
we've already heard of but also another
electron carrier called fadh2 and in the
process of the krebs cycle which is
multiple steps and involves multiple
enzymes we're also making some more ATP
remember that ATP is that really
important energy storage molecule for
the cell it is a very easy way for the
cell to store energy that it can get to
quickly when it's needed now we've
talked a lot about electron carriers we
have the NADH from glycolysis another
nadh from pyruvate oxidation and nadh +
fh d two molecules from the Krebs cycle
now all of these various electron
carriers are going to move to something
called the electron transport chain the
electron transport chain is made up of
several enzymes that are embedded within
the crease stay of the mitochondria so
you can see that this this inner
membrane all of these holes results in a
large amount of surface area so that a
mitochondrion can can contain many many
electron transport chains now the
purpose of these electron transport
chains is that these electron carriers
come to this chain and give it their
high-energy electrons the electrons are
then passed down the chain to multiple
different enzymes and at the same time
energy is being taken from those
high-energy electrons
and it's being used to pump protons
across the membrane
now protons are actually hydrogen ions
which are made of proton and so the
effect here is to get a lot of hydrogen
ions building up in this inter membrane
space so up here is the inter membrane
space down here is the matrix and this
is that inner membrane of the
mitochondrion now the next part is where
we get the majority of ATP from aerobic
respiration all of these hydrogen ions
that have been pumped across the
membrane are then able to flow back down
their concentration gradient so back
into the matrix through an enzyme called
ATP synthase so all of these hydrogen
ions are going to flow back this way and
that is going to power ATP synthase to
be able to turn a DP so adenosine
diphosphate plus an inorganic phosphate
into ATP so it's gonna mean triphosphate
this very important energy storage
molecule of the cell and so even though
there are three places that aerobic
respiration make ATP that is a little
bit from glycolysis a little bit from
the Krebs cycle most of the ATP is made
right here this is why aerobic
respiration is so important the
electrons they're getting passed down
the electron transport chain are
eventually added to a molecule of oxygen
along with a couple of protons making
water so this is why oxygen is required
it is known as the
final electron acceptor and remember
that when there is no oxygen present to
accept the electrons coming down the
chain the electron transport chain will
get essentially jammed up without oxygen
waiting at the end and that will force
the cell to move into anaerobic
respiration which again is just
glycolysis followed by fermentation
you're just getting a little bit of ATP
is not nearly as effective as aerobic
respiration and obtaining energy for the
cell from this original starting
molecule of so that is aerobic
respiration in a nutshell thanks for
watching biology professor I hope you
learned a lot